I want to talk now about the detailed
look that we took last week into all of
the statements and then immediate denial
of those statements of Donald Trump in
the first national presidential debate
against Hillary Clinton
there is a brutal absolutely brutal new
Hillary Clinton ad that calls out Donald
Trump for his little debate it's called
never said that
it absolutely clobber as Donald Trump
let's take a look and listen at that
video
Donald thinks that climate change is a
hoax perpetrated by the Chinese I think
it's real I did not insist I do not say
you even at one time suggested that you
would try to negotiate down the rule
national debt of the United States I
would borrow knowing that of the economy
crash you could make a deal I was
against the war in Iraq just so you put
it at the record tonight otherwise why
are not you why was your does that I'm
right are you for invading Iraq yeah I
guess so even said well you know if
there were nuclear war in the East Asia
well you know that's fine you know have
a good time folks and in fact good luck
folks
enjoy yourself someone who has said
pregnancy is an inconvenience to
employers who has said women pregnancy
is never it's a wonderful thing for the
woman it's a wonderful thing for the
husband it's certainly an inconvenience
for a business who women don't deserve
equal pay unless they do as good a job
as ins men if you become president will
a woman make the same as a man you're
gonna make the same if you do as good a
job you admitted that you hadn't paid
federal taxes
and that that was smart is that what you
meant to say no I didn't say that at all
he didn't pay any federal income tax
that makes me smart so Donald Trump and
Kellyanne Conway have started defending
that entire I guess I would go into a
rack thing as listen Donald Trump was on
an entertainment show
I guess so doesn't mean yes but let's
back it up if your claim all along the
campaign has been I've always been
against it I guess I would invade Iraq
isn't exactly I've always been against
it and last week I told you the
difference between lie lies and
politician lies you can't do an ad like
this if you're Hillary Clinton /
politician lies right like Obama blew up
the deficit you need charts you need
graphs you need definitions how are we
defining the deficit it's obviously
alive at President Obama blew up the
deficit but it's hard to debunk in an ad
just by showing the candidates
statements of verbatim this brutal ad
requires no statistics no explanations
no interjection by a narrator or Hillary
Clinton it's Trump verbatim versus Trump
verbatim contradicting himself and
interestingly enough Donald Trump has
actually continued to repeat lies from
the debate he was repeating that Hillary
Clinton was someone who was questioning
whether President Obama was really born
in the United States he told nh-1 New
Hampshire channel you look at her
campaign and everybody knows it happened
and I would say that pretty much
everybody agrees with me she tried she
wasn't able to do it and I tried and I
was able to do it so I'm very proud of
that saying both Hillary and Donald were
pushing the birther narrative Donald
Trump just did it successfully which is
just absolutely not true now the most
important thing now what thirty
something days out from this election is
will this change the minds of any Donald
Trump supporters and sadly not for many
it's hard to change your mind
if you're not bringing your mind to the
conversation in the first place some I
saw a trump supporter the other day who
said I don't care what he says I don't
care about the media debunking x'
because i support the idea of trump and
he's eventually going to figure it out
if you can get voters thinking that way
you can say whatever you want and that's
exactly what Donald Trump has been doing
now should I be more concerned in light
of this that Donald Trump has this level
of support in spite of doing everything
from mocking a reporter with a
disability to doing a legal business in
Cuba etc etc is the concern that in
spite of that Trump has nearly 50
percent support or should we be really
concerned that in spite of all that
Hillary Clinton is not absolutely
destroying and blowing Trump out of the
water and part of that of course can be
attributed to the fact that Hillary
Clinton is not the most liked politician
or person in the United States but
absolutely brutal ad by Hillary if it
convinces some independents and
moderates to say I can't be involved
with Trump I just can't do it then I
would call it a successful ad we'll take
a break I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
David Pakman show is sponsored this week
by decode DC the podcast that gives you
an honest look into how politics affects
your life the host of decode DC is Jimmy
Williams and he is a very interesting
guy he worked in politics on both sides
of the aisles starting as a Republican
becoming a Democrat he's worked as a
lobbyist he does know his stuff and he's
taking that experience and explaining
the internal dynamics of how Washington
DC works Ducote DC will often dig into
topics that you know I'm passionate
about money in politics for example
including a recent show about why
small-dollar donors don't actually
produce winning political candidates
check it out I did I think you will love
it we are talking about decode DC it's
available on iTunes stitcher or wherever
you get your podcasts